poly do you get in the carpet you're
here to promote a show that features a
relationship you're no longer in yeah
how surreal is that for you um it's cool
you know what I'm saying I get to watch
like I like documenting my life that was
part of my life so I get to see exactly
how they went down and we get to see how
it all went down and I be kind of how it
ended I never know the girl was Pauly D
and ex-girlfriend
Aubrey O'Day give their relationship one
last shot on the new season of marriage
boot camp reality stars Hammadi it where
is holly is there any chance that you
and I we could go back together um I
don't think so
great girl but I we just didn't work out
and that happens just some people aren't
right for each other
Bobby's going back out on the road as
Danity Kane yeah well you'd be spinning
Danity Kane new music for her supporting
her in life
I would love to yes absolutely I want
everybody to win oh wait I love that so
positive always what's the relationship
status today single still I'm single AF
what are you looking for I'm looking for
a good Pauly's it definitely having a
good time right now
he's got two TV shows on the air we're
going back to where it all started where
I met these crazy animals the Jersey
Shore revival just kicked off its second
season which shows more dramatic that
show or this show that's a good question
different levels of drama but you know
what on the Jersey Shore the drama
wasn't mine on this one the drama throat
of mine you know so I guess the more
drama for me is on WE tv
all right then who is causing the drama
in that show well Ronnie has a lot of
drama he has a lot of relationship drama
on Jersey Shore so that all pans out I
got my popcorn I'm always watching the
movie did you share any advice you
learned from this show with your cast
members on that show um no cuz he what
what he's going through is a lot
different than when I was going to but
um he we gave him a lot of advices and
listen there's no one that does
relationship drama better than Ron
joint custody and then she can't say I'm
taking the baby you are driving me crazy
is your psychopath thanks in part to the
success of Jersey Shore move the hills
is coming back yes do you think they
will be as big as you guys have been
with the revival absolutely you know I
just did the VMAs and I interviewed them
on the red carpet I'm excited for that
show to come back and they're very
excited to be back you give them any
advice at the VMAs how to handle it um
no you know what they've been in this
game for a long time they're so excited
to be back so I'm happy to see them back
I don't give me any advice and how's dad
life going she's five now five now yes
very good it's great minyul having a
little mini-me running around amazing
I'm already teaching out of EJ oh wow
are we gonna get her in the booths in
Vegas oh we're gonna see her at on the
show this is love - I would love to yes
you didn't make TV debut yet though all
right we got it we'll keep that for
season three something to look for yeah
there you go possibly
[Music]
[Applause]